we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
voicemail from someone who seems to have
a misinformed right-wing friend let me
put it that way
hi david garrick tear I love the show
keep up the great work anyways a
Republican friend of mine said that
Trump is leading the polls forty points
ahead of any Democratic candidate is
this true
also do you think it's a realistic
possibility that a Democrats may lose
the house in November should we be
concerned about that Thanks
so on the second question first
Democrats are widely expected to
maintain their control of the House of
Representatives in 2020 if that changes
we will have new forecasting for you
know Donald Trump is not leading every
Democratic candidate by 40 points in
fact he's losing to every Democratic
candidate he's losing by the largest
margin to Bernie Sanders and Joe Biden
but Joe a Michael Bloomberg I believe is
also leading Trump in hypothetical 2020
matchups what I will say is I question
how much those hypothetical polls are
worth right now but your friend is wrong
either way there is no factual basis
that would suggest Trump is leading
anybody by 40 points or even four points
in national hypothetical matchups where
it starts to get dicey and we have to
look more at the details and this is why
blanket saying anybody beats Trump in
November or simply saying only Mike and
that it beats Trump in November the
reality is that November is likely to
come down to some key states and when
you look at some of those key states
including states like Wisconsin for
example in hypothetical head-to-head
matchups between Trump and the people
vying to be the 2020 Democratic
presidential nominees those numbers look
okay for Trump and when you step back
and say well we saw in 2016 that Trump
can lose the national popular vote by
three but still win the electoral
college that's when you have to start
and think maybe it doesn't matter that
Trump's losing to Bernie
Biden by four because if it tightens to
just three
that could be accurate and yet if Trump
does okay
in Wisconsin whatever those other key
states are Trump can still be reelected
and that's why I don't know how much we
should be necessarily talking about in
thinking about the race in the context
of those hypothetical matchup polls I
actually tweeted last night I don't
believe you know a lot of people
regularly tweet me they say David only X
can beat Donald Trump in the fall Bernie
supporters will say only Bernie can beat
Trump some Biden supporters will say
only Biden can beat Trump yang
supporters still say yang shouldn't have
dropped out because only gang can beat
Trump Tulsi supporters will say Tulsi
must stay and because only Tulsi can be
trunk I don't think that's true about
any of the candidates
I believe this election is fundamental
fundamental e going to come down to does
the Democratic nomination process do
self-inflicted damage for example a very
ugly convention candidates attacking
each other in ways that will lead to
depress turnout in November that is
question one that will determine the
outcome in November number two what is
the perception of the economy notice
that I don't say what is the actual
state of the economy perception is all
that matters
is the economy perceived to be doing
well it is very difficult historically
this is just the facts it's very
difficult historically to knock out an
incumbent president running for
re-election when the economy is
perceived to be doing well if the stock
market and is up and unemployment is
down that is perceived to be a pretty
good economy even if for a lot of people
stagnant wages underemployment we know
I'm not arguing I'm saying the
perception is what matters I think that
is fundamentally what will determine the
results of November if Democrats don't
self inflict damage in getting to a
nominee it is going to be about who
chooses to go out and vote what is the
turnout and what is the perception of
the economy at the time tell me I'm
wrong I would love to hear from you on
the bonus show today
New Yorkers are dealing with day one of
the statewide statewide plastic bag ban
we have a new image of Earth's new mini
moon and not many Mike May
moon and two women in Boston have been
charged after police say they attacked a
woman and her daughter because they
overheard them speaking Spanish very
ugly stuff from here in the city of
Boston all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show don't miss it become
a member or a patron to get instant
access